μπρούμε αυτό τον τρόπο θα βοηθούμε οι έρευνες δείχνουν ότι μελκτιώνεται μέχρι και ίκωση τη
σεκατον οη επίδωση τους μετά από την αποκόλυση να από το κίνητώ συνεπως είμαστε θετικοί
και ανοικτεί και στην αξιολόγηση έχο μιλήσε και με τη ψέμ που είναι οργάνωση των
μαθητών θα κάνουμε μαζίν αυτή την αξιολόγηση θα το παραακολουθήσουμε το μέτρον και θα μαστε
κοντα να επειδή στην κύπρον είμάστε και δυστυχώς πολλά θέματα τα βλέπουμε μόνος ψήφους υπύρξαν
κάποιες παρα εμβάσεις προς την κυρία μιχαηλίδου πολιτικές παρα εμβάσεις που να ήταν κάποια κόματα
ότι δεν πρέπει να γίνει αυτό γιατί μπορεί να έχουμε ενα επιπτώσεις από τη νεολέα
που είναι αυτιπου ψυφίζουν εναι αυτήπου αντιδράσεις από σύνολα υπήρξε να ποιε με πάρε εμβάσεις
αυτό να μην περάσεις οτι φρατακίνητα ναι πάντοτε υπάρχει τούτι προσεγγησης ε ότι δήποτε πάρουμε
για να ψηφιστεί στη βουλή ζηγίζουν οι άνθρωποι είναι πολιτική καθαρά έχουμε και εκλογές σύντομα
οπότε ζηγίζουντα πράγματα συζητού μαζί μας εκείνο όμως που λέω πάντα είνα όταν προχωρίσμε παιδαγωγικά
κριτήρια δεν μπορεί ο άλλος να αντιδράσει εύκολα και να ξεφύγει πρέπει να μας δώσει
επιχειρήματα τεκμηριομένα δεν στέκουν τα επιχειρήματα να έχουμε να εξακολουθούμε να έχουμε τα γίνητά στην
τάξει αυ κάθε τώσον ακού όταν το πίπτου μηνήματος και σταματούσαν να βλέπουν των καθηγητή
δε λέ ότι δε θα έχει πρόβλήματα η εφαρμογή θα έχει αλλά θα ταλήσουμε αρά
απαντώντας το ερώτημα σας ναι πάντοτε υπάρει αυτός ο κίνδυνος αλλά και εμείς πρέπει ν
ίμαστε πολύ καλά προιτιμασμένοι γι αυτό το κάθετι που παίρνουμε για ψήφυση ή για απόφαση
θα πρέπει να το τεκμηριώνουμε νερευνητικά τώρα ποια νομίζω και ο κόσμος και το ακούο
τώρα που βγαίνω και εγώ στον κόσμο θέλει να έχει επιχειρήματα να καταλαβαν ι γιατί
κάνουμε κάτι πο ως θα το εφαρμόσουμε και να δει και αν το παρακολουθούμε να
μην το εξαγγέλουμε να πλά να το παραο